welcome back everybody
I don't see anyone huffing and puffing
we're very pleased now to have Sudeep
Dogu have you pen telling us about the
stupidest partial optimization thanks
Bobby and thanks to the organizers for
inviting me and for all of you showing
up and those of you who will watch this
at some point so what is partial
optimization so think of your favorite
optimization problem just any
optimization problem for the sake of an
example let's think this is the minimum
spanning tree okay now here's the game
we will play you will give me some input
I will basically ignore your input more
precisely I ignore some part of the
input in the case of MST what this
becomes is the K MST problem where
instead of finding an MST which spans
all the points you actually throw out
key points or think about having n minus
K points now this is a partial function
evaluation I gave you an input which was
end points you decided to not evaluate
it at key points so this is known by a
lot of different names in approximation
algorithms literature robust
optimization penalty avoiding outlier
based and they all basically mean the
same flavor of things and this has had a
very enormous rewarding in rich history
in approximation algorithms so Avram and
their first result of K misty onwards
the number of techniques that got
developed to solve these kind of
problems are fascinating now the
question of course is and I should
mention that more recently there was a
paper run connected nomination and they
actually tried to formalize this partial
optimization and there's a long survey
of results on partial optimization now
the question which we have is if this is
a workshop of uncertainty
an optimization why should we care about
partial optimization problems we may
care about the techniques but why those
specific problems and the answer I was
kind of thinking about Robbie's talk
yesterday and it got me thinking about
the way Optima approximation algorithms
optimization folks typically see this
that you're given an input your
algorithm transfers the transforms the
input into an output and you have a
measure where you measure your goodness
and what Robbie was proposing is that we
should look at different ways of
measuring things
optimism pessimism and something in
hybrid but being more elaborate I would
question the input so one of the first
things I learned in a computer science
class in high school was the notion that
garbage in garbage out if my input is
wrong no guarantees on the output let's
see this is what is being slowly changed
in all the talks which you have seen in
today's in actually today's morning
session let's go back off - what Sasha
talked about let's go back what you
aren't talked about you all saw those
three steps there is data then there is
a model and then there is a prediction
or some optimization and in fact in your
own stroke there was this discussion of
F and F tilde so if you think of it as
an optimization problem it was from F
tilde do something which relates to F in
another sense you're not believing the
input F tilde and that's basically the
question I see this as partial
optimization you give an input which is
noisy you shouldn't believe all of it
but it's mostly true what can you do now
and this ties back to the question which
every math just now is there any notion
of hybrid nests and there is there is a
notion of adaptive refinement I give you
a whole bunch of data what you do is you
kind of optimize something partially and
then what you have not considered in
your input you kind of pay more to
refine them so I give you ten numbers
one
two three four up to nine and then
twenty five hundred you come back and
say is this twenty five hundred correct
and this is an adaptive process one of
the things Commission I showed that if
you are just doing one step refinement
that one step refinement process is
directly partial optimization if you're
doing multi step refinement things get
significantly more involved and you're
on the path to multi armed bandits of
varying degrees of difficulty so this is
why I got excited about partial
optimization let's step back for a
second partial optimization is a
fundamental question irrespective of any
refinement or anything if you think of
adaptive refinement the adaptive
refinement is the following question
what do you know and when do you know it
the wind correspond to the adaptive
steps partial optimization is sort of
the flip side of the same question what
do I get to ignore and when can I ignore
it okay this being said what's new I'll
talk about distributed partial
optimization in the sense the input is
going to be split across s different
players and they have together how to
compute this optimization so why is this
hard
eventually I'd go to distributions and
all of you know that communicating
distributions is a pretty nasty business
you have to send a lot of bits it's not
communicating even in the case of
independent ones it's not communicating
D demand D dimensional vectors and the
problem they should underline all of
this is if your input is partition
between Alice Bob Joe Schmoe between s
players how do they together decide on
which part of the input to ignore that's
a hard problem so and the goal here is
you want to do this in small
communication in space so without
further ado the main technical part of
the talk what am I going to talk about
so if you had a choice of doing
distributed stochastic X for any X
what would you choose I would choose
clustering so what are the models of
classing who here has not worked on
clustering okay
that's it's still a minority class but
that's a substantial minority class so
think of the following model I give you
a four now do not think of partial
optimizations do not think of anything
else it's just vanilla clustering
definition
I'd give you some bunch of points you
know the distances between them I would
talk about the Oracle distance model
specifically that you will give me point
one and point two and I have some crank
which I can crank and get in distance
between p1 and p2 this is a model I'm
talking about so you give me some bunch
of points something happened here it's
an arbitrary metric space or the
distance function the number of input
points will always be in so the target
is you decide to choose K specific
points as centers in this example you
chose those two points below as centers
and you're thinking of covering this
entire space by disks and the measure of
goodness is some function of these radii
you can think of max radius the largest
of these that would be the key Center
problem you can think of the average
radius of these that would be the key
median problem you can think of the
average squared radius of this that
would be the k-means objective function
because k-means is both an algorithm and
an objective function so all of them
fall in the same framework so questions
about this okay
now here comes the partial optimization
I would say that you again have
endpoints you have K centers but you now
get to ignore K points completely so in
this picture if K were to you would
simply not consider this point and that
point and you got a much nicer
clustering
okay this is the problem you want to
solve keep in mind
marshal solutions can be significantly
smaller than the global solution and
this is where it's exciting from an
approximation algorithms point of view
it is much easier often to come up with
much come up with lower bounds for the
global solutions in a partial
optimization because the solution can be
significantly smaller it's a much harder
challenge to come up with good lower
bounds and this is the interesting thing
again distributed setting these points
which you saw up there the partitioned
across s site and the goal is to
minimize communication and louns I was
talking about this to someone and then
they asked but do I still have to give
an approximation and yes you still have
to give an approximation you can't just
say the 0.1 is my cluster Center okay
now what happens to probabilistic yeah
who chooses the way the points are
partitioned is the arbitrary
partitioning or the other great question
for this talk for what I'll talk about
I'll talk about arbitrary partitions now
actually I towards the end I will talk
about partitioning it myself you can
probably get much better results keep in
mind if you get to choose the partition
and if you choose uniform partition
across s sites then someone was asking
me this if you have to ignore T points
you know that you have roughly T bias
points in your data set which you're
going to it becomes a different problem
but it doesn't become substantially
easier if you get to choose the
partition because it's now the ratio of
T versus s so okay what's the
probabilistic setting I gave you I gave
you the Oh
okay sorry I said something should have
been happening so in a distributed
setting keep in mind that if you saw
this data and if I had this data the
difficulties should
labeling this point as an outlier which
in your data of course it is but not in
my data so that's what's the hard
problem here what happens in
probabilistic case instead of viewing
these as specific points view this as
point clouds and for this talk and for
most of what I've worked on assume these
point clouds are independent if they're
correlated things are very hard okay so
questions about the models and
you have Christmas okay all right so
what there are many many centralized
algorithms per probabilistic clustering
I would review like a couple right at
the end I will not for the remainder
talk about probably six clustering at
all I will talk about fixed points given
as input
there are many centralized algorithms
for clustering with outliers one of the
earliest one is by Moses Samir Dave
Mountain Gary nurserymen but there are
very few distributed clustering
algorithms with outliers keep in mind
with outliers is very important if you
think of number of distributed
clusterings there are infinitely many
distributed clustering algorithms for
some value of infinity so this result
which I'm I'm only aware of this one
result this was a result on key center
where you got to ignore T points this
was a two-round MapReduce algorithm the
total communication of number of bits
being sent around was roughly s times k
plus T it was in constant factor
approximation and this was in I guess
nips last year Benjamin Mosley is here
somebody okay now if I ask the question
what is known about comedian ki means
your favorite definition of ki beast
clustering nothing else is known let's
ask another question do you know of any
algorithm for distributed probabilistic
clustering forget outlast for now point
clouds but the point clouds mean the
points are separate in different
locations to the best of our knowledge
no such algorithm is known so what would
we do we would solve the following
problem of distributed probabilistic
clustering with outliers and for K
median means actually sent or even and
this will pick out the entire cross
product of this space
okay what will I show you in the next
few minutes I have I will show you a
meta algorithm which works for general
partial optimization we'll kind of use
it for clustering we can show its
application to other problems which are
similar to clustering why does this work
the reason it works is something which I
had worked with Nina
who's over there we proved something
which was interesting at that point that
a clustering of clustering and this is
the keyword a provably good clustering
if we got a lot of data and you
clustered some of it and then you
repeated this process you would get a
good clustering and you can actually
prove guarantees about it
our people actually also address things
on k-means somehow that has been
reinvented and interestingly this result
also applies to K Center but in year
2000 there were many better algorithms
for K Center and there was no reason to
talk about it but this same idea will
give you a distributed algorithm for K
centers that the clustering of
clustering is a provably good kasseri a
similar statement holds for these other
problems and I will not talk about them
in this so ok so let's see the first
idea the first idea goes back almost two
decades and it's about moving or
perturbing the points it's the same
phenomena that you'll give me an input
and I will keep doing strange things to
it I will not do what you give me so for
example this was I first use this in the
comedian approximation that's long time
back you gave me these points and what I
would do is if this was the feasible
fostering you had intended what I would
do is I'll first move this point to some
other point move this point to some
other point and kind of introduce this
perturbation of course I cannot give too
much perturbation because if I change
everything I can't prove any allergies
in the air now
what I'll assume that these
perturbations which I introduced in the
comedian case sum up to something much
less than your original objective
function we'll keep that in case enter
this perturbation is less than the max
of this perturbation so now think about
this picture
if these red arrows where your original
optimum clustering and I had moved these
by these amounts
I still have an original I still have a
feasible clustering of the blue points
that's the first key and once I have a
feasible clustering including with
outliers I can use a constant factor and
I can get some other feasible clustering
of these blue points my final algorithm
would be to take this some other
feasible clustering move these points
back to their original location and are
done it's pretty straightforward all it
needs is triangle inequality and it
works in any metric space
damnit the question that's next slide
I'll get to that what does each side do
okay okay or actually it's in this so
one way of thinking about this ask each
site each site to solve its km adn with
sake a median okay center with the
outliers and what each side does it
sends you the medians the number of
points assigned to those medians and the
T outliers it has and if you look at
that the total communication is s is the
number of sites K is the number of
medians each of them ignored at most T
points that's your total communication
some central coordinator gets all this
information and just performs the second
step of the clustering and that's it and
it can announce the result and it's
order one approximation it's one round
technical difference with Benjamin's
result this is a distributed algorithm
the result was more in the context of
MapReduce so there is a difference
between what is implementable in
MapReduce and what is not let's not get
there whatever I said so far works for K
means instead of triangle inequality you
have relaxed triangle inequality think
about this that a plus B squared is less
than equal to 2 a square plus 2 B Square
and everything which I showed here works
case and turn everything works just as
is yeah give some intuition for why
preserving the points
yeah I think we'll go back to the
comedian thing I gave you a very
difficult set of points actually there
are other subsequent results by a lot of
other people that you give me a
difficult instance that particular
instance has a lot of degeneracy and
I'll get confused at it if I can perturb
the points maybe I just see the pattern
straight away that these are on this
side these are on this other side and
there's nothing else to do this is
really the intuition yeah I don't have
something better than that it doesn't
work without oh I of course cannot say
that because the original sort of where
we looking at moving these points in the
comedian I mean since then giant vazhi
Ronnie and all these people basically
there's a whole other set of techniques
which apply which doesn't need this
movement so to say that I need the
perturbation I can't say that but it's
interesting but this technique existed
and now to solve a distributed problem I
can lean on it this is all insane yeah
Robbie yes you're clustering of
clustering this is a good clustering
work irrespective of which method I use
lovely all you need is this movement is
not much you can use two different
algorithms or two different phases and
in fact that was the improved result by
Moses Reena and Laden who actually
improved the datastream clustering by
using two different clusterings at two
different phases it does not have to be
the same algorithm Nina
clustering and outliner
do outlier detection
remove the T outliers step 1
great question so I think these are
coupled problems is things are not out
loud just but if I give you one point is
it an outlier maybe this is a hard
question to answer so it can be a joint
decision that I look at the set of
points based on the subset of points I
say that these T are outliers those in
minus T are clustered that's the best
answer I can give
okay so that was idea one now okay
before I go to idea dude so think about
we already have a solution which is s
times K plus T communication so in the
next few minutes let's see I would argue
with you that this communication is not
very good and we need to do better so
think about the following things since
big data is in the range we don't want
to touch big data let's think about a
model modest data you have about billion
points and a very little amount of noise
point zero one percent okay and so
therefore the number of outliers you're
throwing out or number of points you are
not willing to consider is about 10 to
the eighth it's about billion points
it's reasonable to say that our
partition it across a thousand machines
each of them get in the order of
gigabytes this is something which you'd
want to do so now the problem is if your
communication is s times T that's
horrible compared to just communicating
T so the difference between s and T s T
and T is enormous and this kind of keeps
showing up even for small s if you
bought a fancy machine and see that oh
I'll use many cores to cluster and
paralyze this well you might have
improved your CPU your data transfer is
completely make sure that you get
nothing better
and so this communication of s T is
somewhat problematic fundamentally oh
and here yet another reason is suppose
you wanted a by criterion approximation
you're not going to get it from here
actually what may be that if this was
your noise point zero one percent noise
maybe you're okay with point zero two
percent noise really I mean it's such a
miniscule fraction the entire framework
which I showed you so far does not make
it any easier for you to get a by
criteria approximation and that you
would like so that's the idea two
the question is how do I get all the
different sides to agree on the T
outliers and I guarantee you this I will
set up the problem and you will know the
solution it's really looking at a
picture so what am I going to do so
we'll ask the question that suppose each
side could solve the sub clustering
problem what is the sub clustering
problem I have some bunch of data I get
to ignore at most T outliers so I can
compute this profile that this is my
clustering with 0 outlast this is my
clustering with 1 outliers 2 3 4 all the
way up to T so I get this profile it is
monotonic decreasing if I get to ignore
if I get to throw all points things were
decrease the lower bound and it all
comes back to this what is a lower bound
we are interested in devising a lower
bound where the first site ignores T 1
point second site ignores T 2 points
third site ignores T 3 points and the
sum of these three things is at most T
this is still a messy problem and not to
mention I can't get these optimal
profiles so what are you going to do
that cost it hey now what are you going
to do it's in the picture what are you
going to do
just come bexif i the whole thing and
once you convexity this look at the
convex a lower envelope of this that
problem is trivial it's just water
filling if you look in slopes we know
how to solve this we've always solved
this and that's it keep in mind I'm only
interested in the lower bound when I
convex if I this I am NOT saying that
that's any way related to an actual
clustering no but it suffices for my
purpose how does the convex if equation
work so think about this now this is a
constant thing you can take it away no
matter which T you choose you're gonna
pay this and now think of just the
increment so this is zero zero zero zero
and then the numbers keep increasing so
you make sure you I may have switched
this might have been n minus T sorry
that might be confusing so you kind of
take as many low numbers as you can and
that's the best answer you can have
there are other things which you can do
with this this whole profile business
works with an approximation instead of
having this red line you would have some
strange line here which can be arbitrary
squiggly approximations need not be
monotone remember that I can get varying
different approximations but turns out
you don't need to know this full profile
you can guess T in powers of two or some
some other thing it'll wake one point
which our last last point which I'll
talk about what this shows is actually
something fascinating the amount of time
at each site actually divides by a
factor of s so if you had a quadratic
algorithm each of the fights now run a
quadratic algorithm which is n by s and
if there's F of them from an N square
algorithm you actually went to something
which is lower than N squared and this
is a question where you were asking can
I do anything if I get to subdivide and
of course this is what I can do so I can
use this entire distributed algorithm to
speed up the sequential running time now
what is the balance point so this whole
thing is N squared by s I have to
balance that with s times K plus
whatever the what the coordinator has
done so that is what would determine the
balance point but you have one way of
speeding up computation okay I will
leave you one final slide on
probabilistic clustering it's a sort of
one of the early works was Graham
Kermode and Andrew the clustering is
minimize the expectation of some
objective the same objectives we saw
case enter K median the k-means
objective you can think of all of the
same things now
if this is your optimization as long as
the objective is based on an average or
a sum the expectation and the sum is
going to commute and therefore what
would happen is you are minimizing over
some different metric so for comedian
and key
there's really not much else to talk
about the expectation and some commutes
the problem solved what is interesting
is if you are now trying to solve K
Center you now have minimized the
expected max now something which is
known in the literature by many proofs
there are also some variants or profit
inequalities the expectation of the max
is a constant factor of the sum of the
tale bounds and this is something
Commission I use this was also inclined
by Rabbinate are - for bin packing the
proof relies on LP duality actually once
you use that once you use this kind of a
equality what happens is your case enter
problem becomes a comedian problem or
probabilistic case center becomes a
probabilistic becomes a comedian problem
over a truncated truncated set now this
algorithm which we had in 2009 actually
distributes in itself the fostering of
clustering is a provably good clustering
the question now is what about outliers
probabilistic clustering now the point
is if I ignore a point I can't send the
point to this central coordinator have
to send the point and its distribution
and that's a lot of communication so it
turns out what we can do and this is we
can create a different metric and
instead of sending the distribution I
basically send you the one median not
the mean the one median of that
distribution and some other information
on this new metric and that suffices
and this is something again the new
piece this did not realize if you didn't
have distributed business and that's
pretty much all I had to talk about
thanks
questions
each site senders compute the best
clustering if I could
remove for outliers remove a tout lies
all the way up to tea then they would
create this marginal then I let's talk
about on the first site I would say that
how much cost I would incur PowerPoint
when I go from ignoring eight to
ignoring four let's see that's only log
in bits of information you're not going
to send any points you're not going to
send anything you're just gonna send me
log in numbers or log in pair of numbers
one comma the marginal to comma the
marginal for comma the marginal and
that's it that's all I need so the
coordinator is going to find okay I
ignore five points you ignore seven
points switch ignores 25 points and
that's it after that we just solve our
problems and send it to the coordinator
so this is if you see that I have convex
functions and this is a well-known
optimization which is referred to in
many literature's as water filling the
picture which I showed if you turn it
upside down what happens is the
marginals correspond to potential of
water so imagine turning those pictures
and pouring water water will fill up to
the exact height this is the yeah it's
known as water filling
all my outlier clustering algorithms are
by criteria not correct but you mean
so kitchen had a result on algorithms I
showed in now actually no no it appeared
so the it depends on what the
coordinator does in the end so there are
unique right engine approximations for
clustering with outliers in the comedian
case this is Kay Chen's result it's
running time is large but you can use it
in the second step there are four the
key Center result no by criteria is
necessary for key means actually I'm not
sure if there is a unique criteria
result I'm not aware of it but I can't
see it doesn't exist for the
probabilistic key Center stuff the same
thing holds its it's unique criteria
actually what the by criteria are very
good what the by criteria happens is in
the two round case I get to ignore five
points mean I get to ignore seven points
should she gets to ignore 25 points then
what we do is I don't send my five
points I just sent my medians Nina's
answer medians you send your medians
nobody sends any other points how does
the proof handle this you take your
input throughout these two points which
we have together decided to ignore then
throw out additional T points because of
the optimization and that's two T points
yeah you'd have to balance the s times
so it's n square divided by s balanced
with what you'd get is SK plus T squared
it would be a polynomial improvement if
T is polynomially smaller than n if T is
already in this is a this is a bad
situation to do so if the situation is I
have endpoints and I get to ignore n
raised to 1 minus Delta points that this
would definitely be sub quadratic so it
depends on that T yeah it'd be like so
if T is square root n I know it's a
little bit sub-quadratic say n raised to
5/3 something like that you can optimize
this one other thing you can do this
recursively if you are interested if
you're really interested in getting it
to linear time you can do this
recursively but then you would lose in
the approximation factor let's take the
remaining questions offline in thank
city